we have a clip here from the wrong missy
okay and i believe
i don't want to give too much away but
uh david spade
thinks that he has invited someone else
on a romantic getaway
uh but because of a miscommunication uh
texting
he's invited you you show up and i think
this is the scene we're going to see is
that correct
i yeah i don't know you don't know when
you don't care do you
you've changed with your you're not the
lauren lapis i met back in the day
you've got your
curtain now and your striped shirt
and your blue microphone you think
you're all that and a bag of chips
well anyway that's the clip
it's so great to see you
[Music]
you smell so good what is that that's
soap
sorry i'm a little sweaty i had a whole
tsa pat down
guess i'm too sexy no i had a i had
sheila in my purse but
i got away with it because i told him it
was a service knife so
don't worry you're protected
what are you doing here what are we
doing here
what are you doing here what are you
doing here yeah
are these for me those aren't you got me
roses
that is so sweet mmm i wanna
motorboat them
i've never flown first class this is
crazy
wait what's in this bag what in the
world
free stuff oh my god
i didn't have any of this perfect